[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a german satirical comedy
film called look who's back
spoilers ahead achtenzi and octancy
daruf
[Music]
the beginning of the movie is set
somewhere during the second world war in
berlin the fuhrer hitler is with a
behavior coach named keppel hitler
expresses his disagreement with the
gesture of people's greeting to keppel
he complains that though the nazi salute
is out-fashioned people need to at least
raise their hands up to the wrist and
show respect then he narrates that he
has done everything humanly possible to
destroy the foundations of the enemy who
desecrated their soil he finds german's
existence incomprehensible and finds it
alarming that he is here too
in the following scene he wakes up on
the ground somewhere in a forest
looking up to the sky he sees that the
enemy aircrafts are missing and guesses
that they might have taken some rest
suddenly a ball comes bouncing towards
him and stops just at his side he raises
himself and heads towards a building
past the bush he is then approached by
three young kids who question him if he
is okay hitler looks at them and thinks
that they are the future of the nation
he then asks them the way to the street
in that instant a reporter fabian
sawatsky is filming the kids with his
camera hitler is seen on the far side of
the screen he picks up his army cap and
says to himself that he should go to the
fuhrer bunker hitler gets to the street
and is amazed by people riding mono
wheel bikes he finds people capturing
him on their cameras and expresses that
though the rubble went people have gone
mad
then he feels a modern car by his hand
and questions himself if he fell into a
coma and missed the victory he realizes
that he is not aware of his situation
entirely and alerts himself to collect
more information then he asks a man
about the location of chen's celery but
the person instead asks him for a
picture he gets disturbed by the
camera's flashes as people come near him
and take photos in turns
confused by the unusual events around
him he concludes that something went out
of hand in this place as hitler walks
away he finds a woman speaking in german
on her phone he comes closer and asks
her about the current date but the woman
is terrified and sprays his eyes hitler
cries in pain as his eyes get reddish
and his vision gets blurred he stumbles
and walks to a newspaper shop nearby he
gets shocked to see the date october 3rd
2014 written on the paper and falls to
the ground at once somewhere else the
boss of a tv station karner praises mr
christoph sensenbrink for his excellent
job as the deputy's head he proposes a
higher solution but instead announces
another worker named miss katya bellini
as the managing director due to this
kristoff is shocked and dissatisfied he
comes to his office and vents his anger
out at a struggling filmmaker named
fabian despite fabian's best attempts to
convince his boss he gets fired and
thrown out by the guards
some time later hitler wakes up at the
news shop and asks the owner about the
date he confirms that it is in fact 2014
a confused hitler questions if the
shopkeeper has kidnapped him and
suspects that this is all a trick play
of the enemy's secret service he
threatens to kill the shopkeeper if he
is working for the enemy but the
shopkeeper gives him a bar of chocolate
instead hitler opens it after quite a
struggle and sniffs it he declares it to
be industrially pressed grain and
questions the shopkeeper if there is
still a shortage of bread the shopkeeper
asks hitler if they are filming a
documentary somewhere nearby mistaking
him for an actor the shopkeeper then
says that he looks exactly like the
fuhrer to which hitler replies that he
is the fuhrer after that hitler sees the
turkish newspaper and asks if the
shopkeeper has schtermer or panzerbar
the shopkeeper says that he has more
turkish customers hitler is astonished
at the presence of turkish people in
berlin he then starts collecting
information from the newspaper while
reading it he assumes that he didn't win
the war in the past and germany was
given to the hands of clumsy women
having the charisma of a wet noodle he
further laments the existence of poland
and concludes the war to be a total
waste meanwhile fabian looks upon his
video reporting about soccer and sobs
sad at the fact that he was fired don't
worry fabian in a couple years you can
get a job on youtube his mother calms
him and asks him to pause the video
noticing hitler behind fabian is amused
at the discovery of a person who looks
so similar to hitler back in the shop
the shopkeeper asks hitler to keep the
newspaper aside and stand outside hitler
grudges at being asked to work the
shopkeeper suggests hitler clean his
clothes for they stink he then goes to a
laundry place and asks them to clean his
uniform hitler asks if they have another
uniform since he cannot walk away naked
hitler doesn't understand that he's in
modern day germany now and nudity is no
big deal next we see hitler walking to
the news cellar with jeans and a sweater
on hitler's looking bussin fabian on the
other hand has somehow managed to find
him and is waiting for him in the shop
after getting a look at hitler he is
amazed at his appearance fabian asks
hitler if he can film him as he marches
through modern germany hitler agrees
with the idea fabian takes up some cash
and a car from his mother and begins his
journey with hitler the two end up in a
hotel where hitler gets amused at seeing
the television he then decides to talk
about politics in fabian's presentation
he goes to places asking people
regarding their views on politics after
the interviews he finds that there was
minimal impact of democracy upon people
during his absence he inspects
discontent and suppressed anger in
people which reminds him of the 1930s
when people had similar views but lacked
the term political disenchantment people
tell hitler about the problem of
immigrants in the country making hitler
push his idea that mixing the races
doesn't work
later fabian asks hitler the source of
his unique mustache hitler replies that
he cut his mustache to a shape that fits
a gas mask a while later the two end up
on a farm where hitler gets bit by a dog
he is enraged and shoots at the animal
fabian scolds him and seizes the gun as
the tour goes on fabian eventually runs
out of cash but he thinks of a plan and
convinces the passers-by to have their
sketches drawn by hitler hitler finally
gets to exhibit his creative side and
draws sarcastic pictures which people
find funny and pay for
they continue their trip after
collecting enough money
back in town fabian shows a clip of
hitler to kristoff the video has a lot
of views as fabian has uploaded it to
the internet kristoff is impressed by
the large number of views on the video
he asks fabian for hitler's name and
contact number after meeting him
kristoff suspects hitler to be a lunatic
and asks fabian to take him away from
his office before leaving hitler enters
the director's office and asks her to
save germany together with him
interested by the idea bellini asks him
about the plan she quickly asks her
assistant to prepare a proper tv format
for broadcasting the fuhrer on listening
to hitler's idea fabian then threatens
kristoff to give him his job back or
else he will take hitler away on hearing
this kristoff makes him a kitchen boy
promising to promote him when a new
editorial post opens up kitchen boy is
better than an internship i guess
sometime later hitler is given a table
at the tv studio christoph calls
crowmeyer to help hitler with computer
use hitler recalls the computers of his
days and labels the invention to be one
of the greatest crowmeyer tries to sign
up hitler to email but informs him that
his name is already taken hitler grunts
for others stealing his name and tells
her to use new reich's chancellery as he
liked it
kristoff plans to put hitler on a live
comedy show called whoa dude he is still
salty because bellini got a promotion
instead of him and intends to create
trouble for her he intends to bring
racism to the debate through sarcastic
jokes on jews and throw out hitler the
show starts and with sigmund the host
calls for hitler on the stage the
audience gossips about hitler's
appearance but when hitler gazes at the
audience the hall goes completely silent
hitler soon breaks the silence but does
not read out the lines as scripted he
explains that he is to tell a joke about
immigrants but he is not going to do so
he says that a tv is a great invention
of the human but the shows broadcasted
are nonsense clearly hitler hadn't seen
game of thrones yet he sheds lights on
problems like poverty and unemployment
and forecasts that the people of the
country are heading towards the abyss
without noticing it hitler vows to fight
against the tv not only up to the
broadcast of the abyss but also until he
succeeds in overcoming them everyone
likes the idea and claps for him seeing
hitler's popularity the host vitsigman
gets envious bellini asks kristoff to
broadcast hitler in every show kristoff
is distressed because of the failure of
his plan in the following scene we see
hitler give interviews on numerous tv
shows and share that his motive is to
make germany great
wow this movie was ahead of its time his
popularity grows immensely and he meets
several people and party leaders he
starts charming them all by sharing his
ideas one day hitler and fabian visit
npd headquarters in berlin
he calls for ulf biern the federal
chairman of npd and asks him what his
cause has achieved so far hitler
belittles him and says that they have
wasted enough time and the movement is
taken aback by decades due to their
words kristoff gets excited and happy
when the cops and district attorney d.a
appear at the tv studio they explain
that they are here for a complaint of
charging violation of hate laws bellini
asks what they are to do then quickly
kristoff pops that they might need to
cancel the fuhrer show the d.a says that
they can keep the broadcasting on
bellini takes a sigh of relief while
kristoff fakes his smile after the d.a
leaves crowmeyer hands over a letter to
kristoff stating the payment of the dog
which hitler had shot earlier in his
trip kristoff receives the letter
happily believing it might be a way to
cause trouble next hitler is put on a tv
program where he is asked direct
questions about his different roles in
the war hitler responds that he wants to
reach out to people but the interviewer
tells him that all his deeds cannot be
justified he shows him the clip of him
shooting the dog the video disturbs the
audience hitler is angered and threatens
him that he would do the same to him he
further says that he will turn their
studio into a parking lot for tanks
kristoff gets happier seeing people's
negative responses after the disastrous
interview bellini is fired and kristoff
is appointed as the new manager after
that hitler goes to fabian's house and
starts living with him he expresses
amusement at the path taken by destiny
and starts to write his second book the
book soon hits the market three months
later at the tv studio everyone sits in
a meeting where the massive loss that
the company has gone through is
discussed kristoff believes that
whitsigman's show will put them back on
track but one employee informs him that
he has quit his job kristoff gets tense
and mad at the selected employees for
losing the show one of the staff
suggests getting hitler back which
interests kristoff he looks for hitler
again and offers fabian that he will
invest a million in the film that fabian
and hitler are shooting if in return
they let them broadcast the movie on
their tv station hitler and fabian come
to crowmeyer's house where cromeier's
grandmother identifies hitler she claims
that hitler gassed all the people up and
killed them she calls him a criminal and
shouts at him to get out in the car
hitler shares that he is surprised at
crowmeyer being a jew he starts to
belittle jews calling them less of
humans fabian gets disappointed at
hitler's actions and his words back in
the set fabian gets hitler to replay how
he got to the place he asks hitler what
happened before the ball came rolling to
him in the woods but hitler cannot
remember it later at night he walks off
the set and is surrounded by some thugs
they call him the reason to take germany
back and give him a hard blow on his
face as hitler opens his eyes he finds
himself in a hospital in front of
bellini at the same time fabian looks
over the footage of the video he
captured about the boys and soccer he
watches it closely and finds hitler rose
from where he was lying fabian gets
amazed at what happened before it he
quickly goes to the place and finds a
board at the location stating the
historical location of fuhrer bunker
fabian rushes to the hospital but does
not find hitler bellini says that he is
headed to the shooting set fabian
reveals that he is the real adolf hitler
but bellini does not believe him fabian
acts mad and tries to explain his theory
hysterically the guards try to catch him
but he flees
fabian then reaches the set and aims a
gun at hitler when asked about his
identity hitler explains that he never
claimed to be anyone else fabian says
that hitler is fooling people with his
propaganda to which hitler replies that
people elected a leader who shared his
whole idea openly in 1933 fabian takes
hitler to the top of a building with his
gun he corners hitler and declares him
to be a monster hitler in turn claps
back saying that ordinary people elected
an extraordinary man and entrusted the
fate of the country to him he explains
that people chose him because they bear
the same values in their inner hearts an
enraged fabian shoots hitler making him
fall off the building onto the street
soon fabian hears hitler's voice who
says that no german can get rid of him
and hitler who is just thrown down
appears right behind it again
just then belina calls for a cut in the
studio and everyone cheers for the shoot
turns out that it was just a film shoot
and a random actor was playing the role
of fabian hitler then asks everyone to
remember the comrades who could not be
with them somewhere else crowmeyer is
sobbing seeing fabian through a hole in
the mental ward hitler and bolina are
busy giving autographs and interviews to
people after the film booms
as they pass by a car the people on the
street seem fond of hitler and greet him
with respect
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching